when you claims for example that you
throw the baby out with the bathwater
when you're trying to develop and become
a socially acceptable personality that
happens in a different way as far as
he's concerned for each of the genders
and so you one of the prices young would
say that we pay and that this is a very
modern idea in some ways for growing up
as a distinctly gendered society is that
it's very easy for men to suppress and
fail to develop to develop those
elements of their character that might
be considered classically feminine and
it's difficult for women to develop and
express those aspects of their
personality that might be classically
considered masculine but so Jung
believed that nested inside the shadow
in some sense were the Contra sexual
capacities so for example for a man
given what we know about the
temperamental difference between men and
women it may be that men could be more
could develop the capacity for true
compassion and care if they they could
find that ability within what they've
thrown out in the shadow and women for
example could find the capacity to be
aggressive and assertive because that's
part of what they threw out during their
stage of their course of development
because of because of its a priori
categorization as inappropriate behavior
now that doesn't mean that Jung thought
that there was that people should be
raised without any gender identity that
issue never came up for him he just
thought that once you had established a
personality that was sufficiently
developed to be acceptable socially and
functional on the individual level then
you could have the opportunity to expand
that personality and to take into
yourself elements of perception and
thought and behavior
that you wouldn't have had the
sophistication to be able to handle at
an earlier stage of development so young
would say perhaps that if you're a male
you have to become masculine before you
could become feminine and if you are a
female the reverse is true but that if
your development only stops with a
narrow and categorical gender identity
then there are elements that of being
that you could draw on that aren't at
your disposal and that will make you
weak so the shadow breaks up into the
anima animus and the anima is the female
inside the male so to speak and the
animus is the male inside the female and
Jung believed that he could see those
partial spirits manifesting themselves
in people's behavior and so he talked
about a couple of typical behaviors that
he thought were associated either with
anima possession so that would be in the
case of a man or animus possession in
the case of a woman and so he would
regard if you ever talked to someone
who's female who seems to respond to all
of your propositions with nothing but
argumentation for the sake of
argumentation you would regard that as a
manifestation of possession by the
animus and if you ever talk to a man who
is irrationally possessed by second-rate
and futile emotions then he would regard
that as possession by the anima so and
you can see that if you watch for it and
if you believe in such things the best
thing to do when confronted with someone
whose animus possessed is just shut up
because you're not going to make any
headway because the point of the
argument of an animus inspired argument
is to get you to argue not to win
because by getting you to argue the
animus wins